d'un point de vue politique Gérard
Larcher on a vu que le gouvernement
avait donc voulu conclure un accord avec
votre famille politique les républicains
pour ce texte sur les retraites
qu'est-ce que cette réforme change pour
votre famille politique et est-ce qu'on
peut voir là
une amorce peut-être d'une alliance plus
large entre le gouvernement et les
républicains je vous disais il y avait
un instant que j'étais pour une ligne
indépendante autonome je vous faisais
état de points de différence avec le
gouvernement le Sénat c'est toujours été
un contre-pouvoir ce n'est pas un
anti-pouvoir nous nous retrouvons sur le
texte retraite mais je reviens des
débats que nous avons eu dans la famille
politique au moment des primaires nous
pensions tous qu'il était nécessaire
pour préserver le système par
répartition de poser une très clairement
la nécessité de
l'ajuster de l'adapter de le moderniser
et la question de l'espérance de la
question d'une alliance politique elle
s'est posée elle se pose même
écoutez quand quelque chose est bon pour
le pays
je vois pas pourquoi nous nous
interdireions
j'allais dire de voter une réforme qui
nous a pas eu bonne pour le pays dont
tant qu'elle s'est inspirée des travaux
du Sénat
[Musique]